former uh bush administration deputy uh
house chief of staff the architect karl
rove
uh i'm gonna we'll get to the cognitive
question with dr ronnie jackson all
right
we're three weeks from tonight uh
there's nobody that knows
where cuyahoga county is where hamilton
county is
where i can go through all the counties
and you know them all and what they mean
how do you see the race three weeks out
i think there is an effort to deflate
the conservative base
i'm urging people to never trust the
media
yeah well i want to go back to what you
started with because it really is
astonishing
just think about this this is sort of
it's not as bad as
deplorables and you know they cling to
their guns
but what did joe biden just say joe
biden just said you're stupid
he said you can't figure out what you
what affects you
and your life and the prosperity of your
family and your community think about
that
you're right ronald reagan asked the
question in the one debate in 1980
are you better off than you were four
years ago gallup smartly has picked it
up and asked that question ever since
today you're right 56 percent of the
american people say
i'm better off amazing we're in a
pandemic 10.7 million more people have
are without jobs today
why do 56 say that i think they say it
because
in 2017 2018 2019 and through february
this year they
realized they were enjoying better
prosperity than they had been
enjoying for years and they gave
president trump credit for it
by comparison in 2012 in the final
months of barack obama's re-election
that number was 45 percent and in 2004
just before bush got reelected it was 47
but 56
it says something about the sense of
prosperity
and the sense that we're better off and
life is better and
the opportunities are bigger and we've
got more opportunity for our family and
our future and our community
to to today even with all the
difficulties we've got
it shows the strength of the economic
issue the issue of who can better
restart the economy as one
that that donald trump can beat joe
biden on but he's got to do what he did
the other night and that is focus on it
and do the following he's got to have a
narrative he's got to establish a
narrative this is what's critical as we
come down the pike
in 2014 and 2016
he had a narrative which is washington
is broken you need somebody to go in and
disrupt it i am the agent of change
and here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to restore our economy get the
relationship right with china
make america's military strong again and
build that wall
everybody knew what his narrative was he
needs to have that same narrative
that same clarity coming down the pike
here and i think the narrative is this
joe biden's not shooting straight with
you he said he was against fracking in
the in the primaries now he says he's
for it
he said during the primaries and
continues to say i'm going to
get rid of the trump tax cuts and then
turns around and says i'm not going to
tax anybody who makes less than 400 more
than four
i'm not going to text anybody who makes
less than 400 000 a year he's not
shooting straight
he said one thing earlier in the year
and he said something else different
he said in the primary i'm not going to
pack the supreme court now he says
you'll know my opinion
after the election you dummies i don't
just you don't deserve to know what i'm
thinking about this until after the
election is over
so it's two points not showing not
shooting straight with the voters
and the other part of it is he admits he
wants to be the most progressive
president in history that means he wants
to be the most left-wing president
we've ever had and all we got to do is
and all the president needs to do is
go to the democratic platform and go to
the biden
sanders unity task force recommendations
and go around the country saying
here's what he said here's what he wants
to do he led you to believe he was a
different kind of guy a traditional
democrat in the primaries
now he's making showing his true colors
but denying that he's in favor of all
these things that he's endorsed in the
platform
and in the unity recommendations and
trump can do that he's the he
i i saw a guy the other night who was
the happy warrior he came out
he was light he did a little dance he
was he said it had a smile on his face
he delivered the attacks with
not a grim a grim look on his face but
but it like he was enjoying it
and that's the kind of guy if he wants
to win that's what he's got to do
in the next 20 days karl rove the
architect
uh i would just say anybody that makes a
prediction i don't trust anybody
i you you saw the exit polls in 2004
what did they say
uh carl refresh my memory
well the exit polls at uh the afternoon
exit poll said bush was
tied in mississippi losing white men in
florida getting wiped out in north
carolina
and ohio in minnesota and ohio
and colorado and john kerry was going to
be the next president
john kerry yeah in fact they went in and
told him congratulations mr president
you're going to be you know you're going
to be the occupant of the oval office
and the media believed it i remember
that afternoon well we called around to
all the media
saying this is not right three quarters
of the voters in minnesota and north
carolina are not women well maybe he
changed
the nature of the electorate but yeah
look i i'm worried less about election
night
that i'm then between now and then
between now and then the president needs
to have that same discipline
and he was focused the other night he
needs to have that same discipline that
he had when he was coming down the
stretch
in 2016. now he got up and mocked
wright's priebus and
steve bannon and kellyanne conway and
said they tell me to stay on script
and he mocked him but that discipline
was good i saw some of that discipline
the other night
if he wants to win he's going to have to
continue to have the discipline one
other shot
one other thing he's a showman he needs
to be
he needs to figure out how to do this
for example look why not get and get up
one of those big screens and when he's
talking about how biden's not shooting
straight with you like on fracking
go to pennsylvania be in front of a of a
plant one of those chemical plants
that's there
because they they've got the natural gas
revolution occurring there
talk about the jobs talk about the
high-paying jobs put on the construction
running the plan
and then say now he says here's what he
was saying during the primary let's go
to the videotape
here's what he says put up seven or
eight of those have him say it
and then say now what does he say they
don't put kamala harris up there
and put up the president and put the
vice president up there and say he's not
shooting straight with you go to the
videotape wait a minute
that'll become the equivalent of the
karl rove whiteboard
we'll call it the donald trump tele
teletron whatever you call that thing
the big one
all right karl rove the truth the truth
of trump